who can call you out more than anybody
your mama
your mama so let's talk about mama
mai yes jeanie mai's mom has been
dancing's breakout fan
but what happens when you give mama the
mic we made her e.t
special correspondent where did you get
that microphone mom
i have to make it my own you don't have
to make from the my jewelry box i went
to kinko
and i print out and i make it that's how
[Applause]
[Music]
really good i'm so proud of you do you
think you can maintain that number
we'll go up like a 999 or 10
cent or think about just like my breath
go up to the ceiling why you gotta keep
laughing what's wrong with you guys
what does that support have to do with
your brain can you guys beat your scores
this week
i don't want to go backwards in numbers
so i'm gonna try my
i met another one how do you feel
when mom might more famous than you i am
not
surprised good because i'm the g you the
apple
well not so fast because mama my
revealed she actually bet
against genie what do you think should i
give you a chance ginny and brandon
should i so you're asking us if you
should change your mind and vote for us
instead of against us
i'm thinking i'm not sure yet you should
vote for genie
because change your bet put more money
on us and i'm gonna prove you right and
when she wins we want some of that money
yes give us that money well i don't know
yet i'm
thinking about it i'm a tiger mom so
that's why i am
you better do the best otherwise she
part of you in vietnam remember that
the ticket already go one two
pressure's on tonight they're dancing
the rumba meanwhile judge
derek is doing double duty also
performing with girlfriend of five years
and
former dancing pro haley erbert but will
this moment be
a proposal i'm just gonna be straight up
like that
no that's not happening it's just not my
style i don't think you had been ring
shopping you even said
oval shape give me a rough timeline here
because if you picked up the shape that
means
i don't know man i there's this i who
knows
you